for
good afternoon everyone and welcome to
the meeting of the audit and governance
committee held on Tuesday the 16th of
January
20124 um there are no fire alarms today
and the exit are behind
me and please remember to turn on your
microphones when you speak so it can be
recorded before we go to item one on the
agenda we've got some new faces here
this afternoon so I think if we just go
around the table um if we start from
this end and we just do a quick
introduction all the way around
afternoon chair I'm Karen HUD I work for
Dem
Services good afternoon chair my name is
Gordon Bryant um and I'm section1
officer and finance
manager good afternoon I'm the vice
chair Jude
GB good afternoon um senior Improvement
off senior honestly service improvement
officer Anna feay and with me I have a a
t- Lev student from Petro who's um
studying business and he's called
Jacob hello I'm Lauren I'm an audit and
governance Committee Member
good afternoon chair Andrew Davis
external a manager from can
thoron good afternoon chair Joe mccormic
de have an audit
partnership coun forward
appledore right thank you everyone um we
move to item one on the agenda the
apologies for absence to receive
apologies for absence for the meeting
chair we've had apologies from Paul
middlemass the um de AIT partnership
manager and Jo
in welcome
Joe item two minutes of the meeting
um we have two sets of minutes to go
through this afternoon the minutes held
on the 14th of November
2023 and the 26th of September
2023 so I just do a very quick page
Turner Pages
three
4 5
8 9 and finally 10 I'm happy to move
from the chair that those were correct
record I'm looking for a
second second thank you very much Jude
that's councelor gub all those in
favor
okay thank you
so any other anomalies or do we take it
as red right thank
you Declarations of Interest members
with interest should refer to the agenda
item and describe the nature of their
interest when the item is
considered
so item number four the agreement of the
agenda items part one and two well we do
do have a part two this this afternoon
which is the corporate risk register so
um I'm happy to propose that um we will
go into part two at the appropriate time
so again looking for a
second cancel the gub again and just
take a vote on
that thinking that's unanimous thank you
so we'll just take that vote again on
item 13
item five urgent matters brought forward
with the permission of the chair I do
not have any items before
me no additional items from you Gordon
nope
okay item six the external audit
progress report Pages 11 to 22 to
receive a report from Grant thoron
Andrew over to
you thank you chair afternoon members uh
it's a fairly brief update date from
from me um starting uh on page 14 that I
mean that sets out pretty much the
progress of where we are in in January
in terms of the 2223 financial
statements if you remember back at the
uh the auditing governance committee on
the 14th of November we presented that
audit findings report um and then the
plan was was to sign the financial
statement's opinion not long following
that uh pleased to report that that was
signed on the 19th of December and we
issued an unqualified clean opinion in
that regard uh we couldn't issue the
audit certificate closing the um the
audit for the year because we still have
the the value for money work to be
concluded uh and I'll I'll I'll come on
to that next so value for money wise the
original plan was to to bring the
auditor's annual report to this meeting
uh again as I set out back in in
November we had the the officer that was
doing that the vfm specialist had had an
accident and broken her leg she's now
back and she's commence that
work timing wise with Christmas it
wasn't then possible to be able to bring
it to this committee so we've got an
extraordinary meeting on the 20th of
February where we'll bring that report
to finalize that audit and issue our
audit certificate closing the closing
the audit uh in terms of an update on
the value for money work that's
progressing well the field work is
largely completed and we're moving into
the um into the draft report stage uh
and we'll share that with with officers
for for comment as soon as that's as
soon as that's
ready uh after that obviously then
will'll the main focus for us then will
shift to engaging with the with Bishop
Fleming as the council's new Auditors to
make sure we manage that process and
that hand over to them so that's nice
and smooth um in terms of giving them
what they need to start their work and
their planning the other area of work uh
that we've got in progress at the moment
is the the certification of the housing
benefit return it's an annual return
that we do again we're experienc some
delays there and that's largely due to
the volume that we're having to um do at
various councils work well progressed
and that's likely to be signed off in
early early February and my hope is that
when we come in on the 20th that all of
our work and commitments will be
done orbe it housing benefits might
carry on as an engagement going forward
but that doesn't sit within the code of
audit practice um under the code
work uh events wise we've got an event
coming up um in February our chief
accountants workshops and despite us
moving moving on from being the
council's Auditors we will be sending um
Gordon and his team an invite to that
and that just talks about emerging
issues in terms of Technical and
accounting um
and again Bishop Fleming might offer
something similar but the the invitation
will be there and we'll be will be open
for officers to
attend that's all I wanted to say really
chair um there's obviously a sector
update there which focuses more on sort
of delays and to publications of account
which I think you're probably all
acutely aware of anyway um but it's
there for your information um I'll pause
there for any
questions
thank you very much Andrew do we have
any
questions otherwise we just note this
item thank
you we move on to item number seven the
audit reports issue to date Pages 23 to
31 to receive a report from the Devon
audit partnership manager well Joe
welcome to the committee if You' just
like to give us a Brisk run through and
um the floor is yours thank you perfect
thank you chair good afternoon all um so
report on behalf of Paul middlemass who
is your audit manager um so it's a usual
update of work since the last committee
that we would normally bring to you um
but first before I go into those audits
just to regarding the recruitment of
co-opted independent members I know Paul
said that was discussed at your last
meeting um we have receiv received
applications from eight people who we
confirmed have meet the requirements
that we're looking for in terms of
experience and knowledge um you're yet
to confirm if if you're interested in
having an independent member on the
audit committee but just wanted to give
you that update from our side right now
any further questions happy to take
those councelor Ford yeah um on this I
would like to try chair to push forward
with an independent member especially as
I bought up before and it wasn't being
personal if somebody outside I'm all for
Independence and transparency beyond
belief and if there is somebody that
actually has
got um special skills whether that be
legal stroke accountancy because sadly I
don't still I am
outspoken um I do sometimes question
whether some of us or collectively we
could do better and have additional
skills so I'm all for that if we could
pursue that I think that would be rather
useful okay thank you for your
comments Gordon well it is a requirement
for the council to start having
independent members on the audit and
governance committee so that will be
happening soon the bit that's still in
question is whether we go through the
recruitment process that Devon audit
partnership have managed or whether we
look to recruit somebody ourselves there
are a few sort of practical
complications um because the the the
process that Devon AIT partnership have
followed involve a small amount of
remuneration
and we just have to think about how the
remuneration of independent members
interacts with our existing scheme of
allowances so we just have to think
practically about how it can be
implemented come back um thanks for
those comments um yeah in fraps um yeah
we all got to be mindful of the precept
payer fact probably one of the first to
say
that and nothing's ever easy I'm not
saying that but you have it with
standards and one thing other all I'm
getting at with dealing certainly
obvious taxpayers money and whether you
like it or not I think we can do better
and sometimes you can only pick the
football team we have got I'm not having
to go anybody individually but because
of democracy right that's the system we
live in For Better or For Worse all I'm
simply saying is if there is any chance
to diversify and be inclusive and get
additional skills we'd be stupid not to
try to embrace
that yeah I mean the direction of of
Regulation and governance absolutely
agrees with you and that's the direction
we're being pushing no no thank you I'm
not here
argue Happy
Days okay um moving forward any
other points I'll carry on with yes
please do Joe thank you excellent um so
Paul's given me a good summary of the
audit taken place since the last
committee if you've got any real
specific detailed questions I might need
to take those away and come back to you
but I'll try my best to answer those
I'll just give you a bit of a summary of
the work we've done since the last
committee so um within the pack we've
reported on five audits we've given four
four reasonable assurance and one
limited Assurance um opinions on those
um five pieces of work that the audits
included two that related to core
Financial systems and that was main
accounting and dettas so for main ACC we
found controls continue to operate
effectively we noticed several issues
relating to the need to reinstate a
reasonable check on journals over
£100,000 and some delays in
reconciliations these may have occurred
du due to the departure of some key
financi people within the last 12 months
moving on to debt management the process
is generally effective um we identified
opportunities to improve controls and
keeping more detail on what was being
charged in case of any sort of challenge
further down the
line moving on to conservation that was
the area where we have given limited um
Assurance on that area so a specific
conservation officer is not a post of
many Devon districts the role is um s
zoomed into the planning area but torage
does have somebody in that role the
offer takes a wide range of conser
conservation related work which we've
tried to quantify in the work that we've
done um our opinion is based on a me on
meeting the statut requirements which is
listed in the planning Act of 1990 which
relate to um a couple of points here
we've listed decisions on listed
building applications were not being
reached within eight weeks in everything
we looked at there needs to be a bit
more focus on obtaining extensions to
help address this issue going forward
publishing proposals on conservation
areas only two of the 20 conservation
areas have been appraised to consider
consider conservation aspects
so we made a note in terms of additional
resources may be needed to meet that
requirement we um moving forward from
that audit we concluded our assessment
on the work for active torage so the
council owned Ledger company that was
set up more than a year ago for that
audit we looked at debt management
payroll and income management overall we
are content with the control framework
being rolled out there and we've agreed
a few management actions to improve
controls but overall working very
well and then finally we reviewed the
north Devon plus and we considered that
to be a really good example of
collaborative partnership between the
council and North Devon Council that is
achieving its objectives in supporting
local businesses so summary of the work
that we've
done thank you very much that's a very
comprehensive um report there thank you
Joe David do you want to come in
yes Ro
is it possible
because
most definitely in terms of um the ones
that were outside of that time period
I'd need to look at the detail on that
to see just to understand the ones that
we we looked at in terms of that but
you're quite right the role is ever
increasing isn't there I can imagine the
demand on time is um is an issue in
terms of
that thank you chair um I was just going
to um bring up something very similar to
councilor Brenton it does the report
does seem to suggest that we we do need
to have some more staff time on this
obviously we're constrained by budget so
that's a bit of a problem my thinking
was um that we're very lucky obviously
to have a conservation officer who for
whom this is a dedicated Focus but there
are actually potentially some of the
potential benefits of having multiple
people that are dealing with
conservation work is that if that one
post uh if that person should decide to
leave that post we've lost all of the
Knowledge and Skills to do with it it
would be a huge problem I think
potentially for the for the council for
all of that knowledge as wonderful as it
is to be focused in one individual if
that person for whatever reason could no
longer carry on their their roles I
think that's something that we have to
think about um and I just wonder if if
there's any possibility I know that
things are stretched in planning but if
there's any possibility for discussion
of of resources being allocated in a
slightly different way to to to allow
some of those responsibilities to be um
to be uh Spread spread among the team
then that might be um interesting I had
a second question second thought as well
about how the council itself owns its
own listed buildings I wondered if there
is a a list of listed buildings that the
council itself is responsible for and
what it is doing to sort of make sure
that it's carrying out its own
responsibilities for those assets as
well as trying so sort of setting an
example I suppose for what we expect for
our for our um communities to be doing
with their with their list of
buildings yeah okay
um before I come to you Council for
it might be an idea if the committee
agrees that the report goes to the lead
member for planning and brought to their
attention just they're made aware of a
report and the comments you've made and
the committee made but I should go to
you Castor Ford
next thanks chair yeah share a lot of
those views and you're right we're lucky
we've got one and you're right for many
reasons that person could have long-term
illness whatever pick up move or
whatever
um and there is a lot of pressure
actually on that one person so don't
take my next comment to be personal but
it's actually asking a question here as
regards courtesy and
legality is
it fair or reasonable to expect a
conservation officer to turn up on
somebody's property without prior I
could understand if it was an
enforcement officer but I think out of
courtesy they shouldn't just turn up on
somebody's property without prior
arrangement I just think that's courtesy
and you can do things better is all I'm
simply saying because I've got examples
of that and we'll be touching on that it
planning on Thursday
actually
um from what I understand probably you
like any local far we can do better I'm
not here to be critical but you seem
reasonably happy with de m management
which is you know ain't saying you're
ecstatic but it seem Le me happy which
is good but I will also pick up on your
praise I actually will agree so I'm not
here just for ever a winge all the time
I think the northd plus is actually
great actually my dealings with them
been positive so I'm not here just to be
negative chair okay thank
you right um if I could
just raise the issues with debt
management and the
journals that are raised in your reports
Joe if I could just ask the1 officer to
respond to the issues and
recommendations made within the report
um how they're being addressed and what
your comments on them are thank you
Gordon yeah thank you chair no we think
they're all they're all um Fair points
and um well identified with regard to
sort of the non-standard charging that
takes place at the minutes we've we've
agreed locally to improve um
documentation of that so there's a clear
evidence Trail for it um and with regard
to there are systems limitations with
regard to what can be um reported
against in terms of how it can be sliced
and diced so that is an inherent
weakness um so those are the detor
issues um as regards the main financial
accounting systems yes we have looked
again at the Prof forers we have in
place to evidence the technical
adjustments environments and we think
for the most part the existing um
document does do a good enough job but
apparently you know if we can just
document it as when we complete these so
that we're clear whether it is a a
formal environment or just a technical
adjustment that would be on
those okay thank you very much Gordon um
do you want to respond to that in any
way Joe or you no the as part of the
audit process obviously we de brief with
the client um as as and when the audit's
taking place and we've receed those
management responses which we're
satisfied with um obviously any audit
work which is limited like conservation
we will revisit next financial year so
we will go back and look at those high
and medium risk issues that we've
identified in those then bring back
further assurances to yourselves on how
those have moved forward okay well thank
you very much indeed for those reports
um very informative as ever and the
committee will
note the reports that have been
issued so we now move on to item number
nine
the code of corporate governance pages
40 to
and beg your pardon I've
skipped
one audit actions issued to
date item seven order audit reports
issued to date Pages 23 to 31 to receive
a report from the Devon audit
partnership that
management yeah sorry I thought
i' right I beg your pardon I've been
writing too many notes over my agenda um
item eight audit actions to date Pages
32 to 3 9 to receive an update from the
service improvement
officer thank you um I get sent all of
the audit reports and then I monitor the
actions to make sure that the services
are actually um complying or doing the
actions um so this is just to let you
know that this the agenda went out last
week but I have actually updated it
since then so it's an ongoing process of
making sure that the actions are updated
so to date there are 40 actions on the
um audits that have been published so
far 10 or open 23 are complete and then
seven that are late and I'm reporting on
all of them even if they're low priority
because um we it's still important that
we look at them all um so first of all
the emergency plan this is the first one
um this is we've had a new manager and
he's come in and wanted to change a lot
he joined in just at the end of the
summer and so that's why this is quite
late you can see it still looks like
it's really quite late March
2022 was when the target date was I
haven't got a new date for it yet but he
and I are going to meet to talk about
the timings and the changes that he's
making um so it's just to keep you
informed that these are still things
that we're looking at even though the
audit was from 2022 to 23 they're still
outstanding
founding um the business continuity is
the same it's the UH responsibilities
just changed so there's a new manager in
charge of this and he is also going to
be
reviewing um the business
continuity they are going to be reviewed
also um upcoming um with the business
plans that the service managers are
providing at the
moment so we had dettas that were
outstanding I've been to see the team
leader and we she and I discussed it and
she feels that the reminders are being
sent out um to colleagues but it's a bit
ongoing in both of the top two because
there there's a reminder sent out but
they need to be sent out on a regular
basis um to to ensure that all of the
officers
are providing more detail and submitting
them T in a timely fashion um the third
one on there hasn't been um able to be
done because they're tendering for new
enforcement
agencies um so that's the explanation as
to why that's not there and so I'll keep
monitoring it and keep um going and
chasing them to make sure that that
they're
done and these ones have all been done
since the agenda went out so um again
the reminders are issued um the detas uh
2.6 it has been investigated as to
whether these systems um Can whether
there is a system that can provide an
alert but there just isn't any way of
doing that um so although the the action
was to consider how to address it that
they haven't managed to do
so um
and yeah that one was the the again the
the final one was about um processing
the delays and making sure that
everyone's got the information that they
need and then finally the conservation
one which is only just due so I've met
with the planning manager and um it is
going to be ongoing process of
review they're not going to know how
that's going to impact the actions yet
so that's why of keeping it open so that
I can just keep checking up on that to
make sure that it's not forgotten
about
so that's what I've been up to hopefully
if you've got any questions I'll try and
answer them but I may have to bring it
back to I might have to go away and come
back with the answers and thank you very
much indeed um any questions coun Ford
yeah
nice to meet you so again don't take
this personal because you're KN in the
role but this is actually a very serious
question so if you can't answer it now
bear in mind it's taped as well which
I'm aware
of I would like a written response okay
I'm councelor Ford appledore
okay what has concerned me I've already
put this in
print and when we're talking about audit
we're talking about audit and governance
so that
to me includes everything both Financial
ethical
whatever we used to have and bear in
mind with the post office and what's
happened and we all know what's happened
with that so it's very serious point I'm
making not personal but
serious we used to have an
assigned foi officer that would deal
with freedom subject access request we
back at metf okay
I am not happy with the generic
responses the council sends out and we
for by I have struggled as a councelor
to find out who the designated officer
is now I'll go
further councelor for where is this
relevant to this agenda she's working
for improvement audit or
no offic yeah is this relevant to one
right you don't you always want to shut
me down that's for no I'm just I'm just
tying it into the
agenda I'm just looking for questions
relevant to this particular gender
item it's relevant to know and the
precept pair to know that our Freedom of
Information setup is compliant I've put
in writing I don't think it is I think
it's very relevant to good
governance I'm just looking specifically
to that agenda item and it's not on that
agenda item so do we have
any any issues on the report that's just
been
given no okay well then I will
note item number
nine and we will move on to the forward
plan plan on page
sorry I thrown there um agenda item 9
the code of corporate governance pages
40 to 54 to receive a report from the
service improvement
officer all again thank
you
okay um so this is the code of corporate
governance unfortunately the first
agenda had the wrong document on it so
that's why you've got hard copies of
this one um I'll explain a bit about it
this is just just approved we're hoping
you'll approve it today it roughly stays
the same um we read it and review it
every year and then using the code of
governance we report to you with the
annual governance statement which will
come to you probably in April
um so I just want to point out I'm not
going to go through it too much I'm just
going to point out the bottom paragraph
on here because it really explains it
well each year the council undertakes a
review of its corporate governance
Arrangement and at the end of each year
produces an annual governance statement
which outlines the effectiveness of the
code of governance and its application
suggesting areas for improvement and
recommendations um so there
are seven principles that have come from
the sipa and Solace Chartered
Accountants that we um that operate the
principles of good practice and
management so that's what we um we use
to go to so the first one is behaving
professionally and these really are for
officers and uh members so this is how
we do our governance so the seven
principles of public life is
selflessness integrity because it just
mentions it there objectivity
accountability openness honesty and
Leadership so those are where what the
local government um Authority
says principle
B so it's about being open available for
the
public Consulting with stakeholders and
ensuring good
communication principal C consider ing
the impact of decisions in relation to
this principle making sure the policies
are in
place um principle D is so that's about
decision- making and monitoring the
outcomes and um monitoring
risk principle e is controlling the
protocols and ensuring that systems are
in place for Recruitment and monitoring
performance of leaders and officers
and then we've got principal F so that's
about Performance Management Systems in
place Audits and Reporting we do this
with the qbr and making sure that
everyone's informed
um and that this with the council are
under
scrutiny and there the principle G is
about accountability being
transparent and um reporting for the for
public scrutiny as well which is why
things are put on the website and
things um so just towards the end of the
code of governance this is the key
functions of the code of
governance and then the end is how it
all sort of works with the officers and
also the
Committees that was a brief GR through I
know but um that's what we'll do and I I
will be be reporting on that in the
annual governance
statement okay again if there's any
questions I'll try and answer them very
straightforward okay and we just would
like to approve it if we can yes um I'm
happy to move
it oh let's take questions
first
right
chair yes sorry um so when the correct
document was sent out I updated the
agenda as well so that's why you can see
it because obviously you use your iPads
to um scroll through the agenda so I put
the correct document onto the agenda for
you
today
yes David did you want to come in
there
e
yeah Gordon you'd like to respond yeah I
I believe chair that the the structure
that we work within is one that's given
to us and if legislation changes and if
a duty of Canda becomes um um you know a
fundamental part of it then the then the
framework that we're obliged to work
within will change as well but this is
the this is the one that was given to us
from from C for and solid
and this is the one this so it's just a
way but there will still be a way of
introducing our compliance with the duty
of candid if that becomes a fact within
the the principles that are already
there so we if it was an important
change then we would be updating the
code of cport governance for it
we
rules in terms of the overarching
framework we're governed by this but if
we wanted to introduce our own duty of
cander then then if if it has a unless
it has a particularly unique meaning
then yes I don't see any reason why we
couldn't I mean is that a debate for the
for the full
Council
ISS policies of
council
it could go
to we could bring it to the attention of
CNR under the as yes
but looking at the point you make and I
understand where you're coming from we
would have to draw up the wording of a
duty of
candle uh
um
are
there do we have an
example Gordon I mean I'm happy to take
that forward and to discuss that with
the with with the monitoring officer I
mean it's it's absolutely something that
we can take forward and consider but I I
think it's you know it's it's a big ask
for um for for a for you know relatively
fundamental change in in in governance
councelor Ford briefly um then I'll be
leaving and that's for a legal reason um
but carrying on from councelor Brenton
you I think it needs to be spelled out
anyway you're absolutely right to
suggest what you've done but I would
like the1 officer to
explain uh under the Human Rights Act
about the importance of f disclosure and
as I've asked before
for um again relevant with the recent
post office and governance about why the
F council did not discuss willful
blindness and its impacted on local
Authority or public
organization Gordon do you want to come
back on that yeah thank you chair well I
well I can talk about the the seven
principles of public life are referred
to in the in the in the in the code of
corporate governance and that does talk
about openness and objectivity and
Leadership and these kind of facets so
you know in terms of some of the
principles that are being brought out
here that there there is a very very
much a you know a close overlap with the
with with with the line of
questioning I don't want to label on
this simply there is and it's come out
recently and you would know this I've
only got a level a law I'm a thicko but
there is f
disclosure not just showing people what
you'd like to it's meant to help the
little man against the the big boys
that's a fact is it full disclosure I
think it's been since 2018 something
like that human rights you should be
right aware of that which would cover
the point that com to Brenton saying if
we actually play so I have this bit of
paper with rules isn't it that's great
but that there to me I wouldn't even W
you know which is why I want to leave
because I would abstain on that that can
be noted and it's a public meeting a bit
of paper with rules on it to me is
worthless unless everybody follows them
simple simples and with that I am
leaving because like I say
I Bond please Gordon yeah I was going to
say one thing I mean you know in terms
of the principles around full disclosure
I mean let let's not forget in terms of
the obligations that already exist you
know we already um publish spend all
spend over
£500 um there's you know the accounts
process as well there's Freedom of
Information and within the accounts and
audit regulations as well individual
counter tax payers can come in and look
at vouchers and receipts directly
themselves if if if they wish to so
there's there's a lot of obligations
that that are already in
place okay thank you that's um a
satisfactory answer to that
um I'm going to suggest from the chair
that we
adopt the code that we have before
us
and also if Gordon you can go back to
our monitoring officer and raise the
issue of the duty of
caner to see if we can accommodate that
into a future document but if we have a
document in place from today at this
juncture we've got something to work
with going
forward how would you feel about that um
David
I I think that sets the
B
yeah I appreciate where you're coming
from I don't think we can word something
today no no um but if we
adopt this code of corporate governance
as it stands we've got an ongoing
framework to go with and then our
monitoring officer can examine the issue
of the duty of cander and maybe come
back at a later date with something that
we can incorporate into the document I
think that's the best way forward Gordon
yeah yeah I'm sorry I couldn't give a
more thorough answer but I just think it
requires a bit more of a consideration
as to what we'd be agreeing to and what
the responsibility is attached to it
would be if we were to agree to
something
immediately right I'm happy to move that
from the chair for the adoption of this
document as it stands I'm looking for
seconder I'll second thank you very much
dude so if we put it to the vote all
those in
favor
against and
abstentions so that is carried thank
you and we will now move on to item 10
on the agenda which is the forward plan
so we just review what we've we have got
um do you want to talk us through that
it's fairly straightforward do you have
any
next I think you're on it there we go if
you want to talk us through it Gordon
yeah well this just highlights that
we've got um another extraordinary um
meeting in February um with the external
audit to pick up upon the the vfm work
and to get the um the final audit
findings report um and then in April um
there's some more um sort annualize the
work that appears on an annual basis so
that's the draft audit plan with the new
um external Auditors um and the health
and safety audit outcomes and plus those
items that that occur
regularly okay
Lauren
I can add that you can add that in
okay right so we we're happy with the
forward plan so we move on to item
11 and I wish to move that the public be
excluded from the remainder of the
meeting because of the likely disclosure
of exempt information by virtue of
paragraph 3 of part one and paragraph 10
of part two of schedule 12a of the Local
Government Act
1972 I'm looking for a seconder Jude
thank you and um if we take a vote on
that
please all those in
favor that's
unanimous